as possible record-setting crowds fill
airports Nationwide passengers May
encounter new technology at the security
line at 25 airports in the U.S and
Puerto Rico the TSA is expanding a
controversial digital identification
program that uses facial recognition
this comes as the TSA and other
divisions of Homeland Security are under
pressure from lawmakers to update
technology and cyber security Chris Van
Cleave has more
good morning at the world's busiest
airport in Atlanta all right you're
fully verified you can step around have
a great day the TSA checkpoint has
gotten a high-tech upgrade you're going
to take your ID inserted into the
using this facial recognition camera
system to compare a Flyer's face to
their picture on their ID in seconds all
right ma'am you verify thank you very
much you can step around if there's not
a match like here in this demonstration
the TSA officer is alerted for further
review it's showing that the ID
validate D is showing non-matching
because those are two different people
we view this as better for security much
more efficient because the the image
capture is fast and you'll save several
seconds if not a minute TSA
administrator David picoski how does
that speed things up well facial
recognition first and foremost is much
much more accurate and we've tested this
extensively so we know that it brings
the accuracy level close to 100 from
like mid 80 with just the human looking
at at a facial match the program has
been rolled out to more than two dozen
airports Nationwide since 2020 but is
currently voluntary for Flyers most
images are deleted after use but some
information is encrypted and retained
for up to 24 months as part of the
ongoing review of how the technology
performs there are Skeptics five U.S
senators sent this letter demanding TSA
halt the program you don't have to
compromise people's biometric Security
in order to provide physical security at
airports you can play and privacy
Advocates worry about the lack of
regulations around facial recognition
and its tendency to be less accurate
with people of color you have five
Senators that have called on TSA to stop
the program why continue moving forward
with it I agree with them in that I want
to protect privacy for every passenger
and I want to deploy technology that's
accurate and doesn't disadvantage
anybody as for passengers opting to use
it this is a lot of quicker way to get
through got nothing to hide so no no
concerns here I think it's great
TSA plans to add the technology to at
least three more airports by the end of
the year for CBS mornings I'm Chris Van
Cleave in Atlanta